[Music]
more money is flowing into new startups
than ever before but why is that and can
all of them make money i'm alex webb and
this is the attention economy where we
look at all the ways that global
business is fighting for your attention
last year venture capitalists poured 1.4
billion dollars into publishing startups
in the us and europe more than double
the amount of any prior year there's
been an explosion of well capitalized
news startups with names like airmail
puck punchbowl protocol grid the
information tortoise and axios not
forget of course sub stack which lets
writers create subscription newsletters
even my boss's boss's boss justin smith
is getting in on the act and leaving to
found his own new startup and
established media companies are paying a
lot of money to acquire some of these
firms the new york times just agreed to
acquire sports website the athletic for
550 million dollars and axel springer
the german giant wrote a check last year
for a billion dollars to acquire
politico the thing is has anything
meaningfully changed in the economics of
news well the short answer is no not
really what has changed slightly is the
approach the one thing these websites
mostly have in common is a keen focus on
a given subject matter so the athletic
as you might guess
focuses on sports in the us and uk the
information well that's a tech website
originating in silicon valley pup
meanwhile describes itself as being at
the nexus of hollywood wall street
silicon valley and washington they tend
to hire established journalists who they
hope will bring an audience with them
politico is the og here what started as
a dc news sheet has since evolved into a
glossy chronicle of politics on both
sides of the atlantic the key is to
build a passionate audience if you can
do that you can maybe circumvent some of
the tech gatekeepers like google
facebook and twitter by convincing
people to come straight to your website
and if you can get that loyal audience
you can then think about how to make
money from them in fact it's a playbook
straight out of silicon valley there are
fundamentally four ways to make money
firstly of course digital subscriptions
the new york times has turned that into
a 600 million dollar a year business
then there's licensing where you can
think about selling your stories to
other publications
then you've got the advertising business
of course not quite as lucrative as it
once was and finally commerce where you
can think about selling some of the
products that your journalists review
that last one is the business model for
future plc it's britain's best
performing stock of the past five years
it's returned 2 000 to investors and
snapped up established magazine brands
like the week horse and hound and
country life in the process the key
seems to be to start small focus on a
given subject and do it well before
thinking about expanding if you can do
that it's lower risk for investors and
in the world of remote work and cloud
computing a small amount of capital can
go a long way
[Music]